nous avons déjà parlé et présentait
d'ailleurs le phénomène punk punk c'est
un mot anglais qui veut dire minable
moche
les peintres se font remarquer par une
tenue volontairement minable provocante
preuve qu'ils attachent plus
d'importance à ce qui peut paraître
important à d'autres personnes
les pinces aime la musique et en
particulier le rock'n'roll
c'est pourquoi ils s'étaient réunis ce
week-end à mont-de-marsan pour un
festival punk
objectif faire peur choqué bousculer les
habitudes objectif raté il faut bien le
dire du moins à mont-de-marsan
car ils n'ont réussi à susciter que
curiosité d'étonnement indifférence
parfois peut-être aussi pitié de la part
des montois les habitants de
mont-de-marsan
autrement dit les indigènes curieuse
parodie des monts
bien difficile de trier dans le lot le
mot open cache en fait beaucoup de
choses bien connues toutes catégories
sociales réuni l'ensemble en mal de
fantaisie certains arrivent en voiture
de sport
d'autres nuque et ici le punk des bas
quartiers au toit le punk parfume
en tout 70 francs les deux jours de
folie seul point commun ont mis la lure
la musique du rock presque sans foi ni
loi
mais terriblement y tenait